all right we've got so many Easter eggs
from into the spider-verse to share
there's not a moment to waste
did you notice how they don't wait wait
I also have a ton of incidence by
diversity to eggs to share weight you
should eat more you're in the movie in
there University my universe are most
internet videos about Easter parking
Jake Johnson here and we've got so many
Easter eggs from the new clay animated
video game enter the sparta brush to get
through another universe it happened
again the first reference comes before
the movie even starts guys we might be
here all day
everything opens with the comics code
Authority seal of approval
in years past this was the comic
industry's way of governing itself and
avoiding government censorship the seal
appeared on the covers of Marvel Comics
from 1954 until they stopped using it in
2001 the code required comic book
publishers to make their villains
unsympathetic so I'm actually not sure
if Aaron Davis's the Prowler would
qualify in this case he's pretty
sympathetic I like that guy this wasn't
the first cinematic appearance by the
character by the way Aaron Davis was
also the name of Donald Glover's
character in spider-man homecoming is
that guy gonna turn into the Prowler at
some point maybe speaking of mr. Glover
there's a brief clip from community
featuring the actor in a spider-man
costume it was produced during his
public campaign to take on the role of
spider-man which eventually went to
Andrew Garfield
apparently Glover's campaign helped to
inspire Marvel to create Miles Morales
in the first place and as a nod to this
history you can see a brief omage to the
original community scene on Aaron
Davis's TV during Myles first visit Wow
that is a deep cut and a messed up
origin story another little tribute to
Marvel's history comes during the
sequence when alternative reality Doc
Ock is opening her dimensional portal a
computerized map shows her navigating
between other universes with one
identified as earth-616 this is the
primary reality that most Marvel comics
take place miles his story is set in
what's often called the Marvel Ultimate
Universe which is earth one six one zero
wow that's a lot of earths
now is into the spider-verse opens miles
his universe had its own version of
Peter Parker this is the first
spider-man we see active in the movie
he's voiced in a surprise appearance by
Chris Pine easily one of Hollywood's top
200 Chris's that's also him singing
Spidey bells over the end credits based
on his intro montage it seems like this
Peter Parker may be the same one
featured in all those Sam Raimi movies
he does the upside-down kiss from
spider-man one stops the train and saves
Mary Jane and the cafe from spider-man
two and he even does the familiar street
strut from spider-man 3 miles reads the
in universe comic book true tales of
spider-man which relates the stories of
this Peter Parker's various adventures
the covers are all inspired by real
spider-man comic book covers in the past
including his debut and amazing fantasy
number 15 and Spidey's face off against
the chameleon and amazing spider-man 186
there's also some specific shoutouts to
spider-man's creative team over the
years if you watch closely while miles
Scrolls through the contacts on his
phone there's a B Bendis in there a
reference to writer Brian Michael Bendis
who co-created miles character
spider-man co-creator Steve Ditko gets a
similar shout out he's among the name
saved in miles dad's phone at another
point miles races through the streets of
New York past a shop called Romita ramen
a tribute to artist John Romita senior
who helped to find Spidey's look in
style but let's jump ahead to the
underground Spidey layer which Aunt May
reveals late in the game to our heroes
as Miles and his new friends take the
elevator down they pass by where the
spider mobile and spider cycle are being
stored we also see where this version of
Peter Parker was storing all of his old
suits Spidey has worn all of these
ensembles over the years some of the
looks on display include the suit from
Marvel's secret war event the stealth
spider suit Peter created to combat the
Hobgoblin sonic screams an electricity
insulated suit The Scarlet Spider suit
worn by flawed Peter Parker clone cane
parker avenger Spidey's iron spider
armor and the suit from sony's recent
PlayStation 4 spider-man game that
post-credits sequence was also steeped
in classic spider-man lore it features
Miguel O'Hara from the spider
in 2099 timeline in these stories
created in the early 90s by Peter David
and Rick Leonardi O'Hara is a geneticist
living in future New York known as nueva
york and trying to recreate the
abilities of the original spider-man and
other people did you recognize O'Hara's
voice that's right it's Oscar Isaac
taking a brief break from one of the 800
other movies he's made this year and
this post-credits scene though O'Hara
takes a portal back to the 1960s and
invades an old episode of the classic TV
spider-man cartoon this segment with a
cartoon Spidey pointing at himself
originally comes from the 1967 episode
double identity and has become an
internet meme you can tell because it's
so dank there was another trivia - the
Internet's love of spider-man memes
visible in miles dorm room he has a
poster of a cartoon spider-man sitting
at his desk hanging underneath his
chance the rapper poster Oh also
alchemax the evil corporation that the
kingpin is working with in spider-verse
originally comes from the spider-man
2099 series they're one of Miguel
O'Hara's main adversaries we already
talked about si pine but spider-verse
also features one of Stanley's very last
cameos as the owner of Stan's
collectibles he's the guy who sells
miles his first spider-man suit and if
that weren't enough post Malone who did
the song sunflower for the soundtrack
also shows up in a brief vocal turn as a
nameless Brooklyn resident but aside
from celebrity guests a lot of
spider-man characters show up briefly in
the new film kingpins goons are
tombstone and scorpion who have both
tangled with Spidey in the past and
Kathryn Hahn voices the villainous
Olivia Octavius the version of Doc Ock
from Miles his universe there's actually
been a female dr. octopus style villain
in previous spider-man comics but the
Olivia Octavius name is new previously
the character was known as Lady octopus
and her real name was Carolyn Trainor
Jenna flippin Doc Ock is just one little
way that the filmmakers differentiated
Miles universe from our own they also
have their own Coll ads office buildings
advertisements color schemes you
an alternate time square for example you
can see an ad for a Seth Rogen movie
called hold your horses which sadly you
can't go see in our world there's also a
billboard for a Broadway show called hi
hello this reference is the real
Broadway comedy show oh hello
which starred Nick Kroll and John
Mulaney Mulaney provides the voice of
spider-ham aka Peter porker in the movie
wow that is a long way around but I mean
we got there
those Times Square ads went by fast and
sometimes they had spider people flying
in front of them
so we're worried we may have missed a
few if you caught ones that we didn't
mention drop us a comment let us know
cuz you're like me I didn't think there
was anyone like me
[Applause]
you
[Applause]